[Music]
hi
have you ever been in a situation where
you couldn't remember the word you
wanted
don't worry it happens to everyone even
native speakers and in a speaking exam
when you're maybe nervous and stressed
it can be even worse so here are four
things you can do to communicate when
you don't know or can't remember a word
in english
the first technique is to find a more
general word or explain the word for
example if you can't remember the word
surgeon you could say doctor or if you
can't remember the word kitten you could
say
baby cat
[Music]
describing the purpose of an item in a
sentence can also be useful if you don't
know the word scissors you could say
they are used to cut paper or they are
used for cutting paper this works best
for nouns
for nouns and adjectives you can use
synonyms synonyms are simply two words
that mean the same or have a very
similar meaning
for example clever is a synonym for
intelligent and stone is a synonym for
rock antonyms are opposite words you can
often describe an adjective using the
opposite adjective if you can't remember
the word old you could say
not young for example
one more technique to use when you can't
remember a word is approximations
you can say it's like a house or it's
kind of a house with only one floor when
you're trying to describe a bungalow
remember you can always use more than
one of these language techniques at once
so if you can't remember the word for an
office block you could say it's a kind
of tool building where people go to work
at desks
[Music]
for more tips on learning english and
preparing for your exam subscribe to our
channel and visit the learn english
teens website where you will find loads
more learning material to help you
improve your english
[Music]
you